great well for people who are joining on
live stream this is a continuation of
our discussion about the future of data
set and we're looking at a bunch of
details about how data set will work in
the future now Chris did you I was just
in a cloud development meeting and we
were just looking at um just talking
about saving of this we have this
concept of a save persistent um what is
it called we just invented a name for
this in other words taking a data set
and when you cloud publish the notebook
that contains the data set also
publishing a separate cloud object that
is essentially the backing information
for that data set uh-huh right yeah so I
think Matt Kay is going to project
manage making that happen I believe okay
um but that's gonna involve you and
shadi and anybody else that you know of
who has backing data like that okay um
okay
live streamis is saying please test this
with thousands of with datasets with
lots of data in them um
Pascal vo C I don't know what that is
should be a good dataset example would
love to see datasets backed with spark
and other such things um yeah the
front-end can't handle data of like 10
gigabytes of data yes that's true I mean
this is something we hope to do going
forward um and uh I mean I I think Chris
once this round of stuff is done we need
to look at what's happening with the
file back database data sets that was
exactly what we planned and database
back data sets
yeah who's working on that well the file
back data sets Leonid had developed all
the stuff like two or three years ago
but it was never deployed so the main
issue is how do you get a file back data
set okay so in other words let's say
you've got a five gigabyte data set
where did it come from if it came from
some giant CSV file that you then the
first question is how does that import
work and does the data set look at the
thing in its raw form without importing
or does it reprocess it see what I'm
saying mm-hmm
and what leonid had done is he built
this thing which does processing of big
arrays in chunks but I believe that the
innards of the big array have to be an X
file format or something okay so it's
unclear what happens whether you whether
that's an acceptable thing to
pre-process the CSV file into chunks of
M X file stuff so that it can be
processed because that can be done
offline obviously and in in parallel and
so on or whether one needs to be picking
up the R or MX
you know raw file now similarly with
databases we now have all of this
database technology and I don't see any
reason we shouldn't be able to use that
automatically within a data set in other
words retrieving stuff on demand to fill
in pieces of the data set that makes
sense
who's working on that that's the group
well Leonid Carlo Ricardo okay under
Todd okay and those young people should
talk to I think that's probably the
nearer term thing to do and the very
interesting thing to do is to have I
mean that's non-trivial because
operations that are going to be done in
data set only some of them are compiled
able to run on the server side see what
I'm saying yeah for files that's less of
an issue and for spark that's less of an
issue because we can actually have
wolfram engines running of the spark
nodes right but we looked at sparkin and
dillon be uh had a preliminary version
of that and i I think it we were thigh I
think who does he work with now is he
working with Todd now I'm not sure or
perhaps with Joel um but it we were
finding out what's happened to that and
I did see that on his roadmap still I
don't know what's happened with it I
think we just didn't know how to deploy
it because you know by the time we you
know people have existing spark
installations and we need to understand
how they will actually use this stuff
unless we think that what's gonna happen
is they're going to unfurl a spark
installation just for this but I think
that's implausible because you've got to
have machines and all kinds of things
hmm makes sense yeah all right let's get
to work here okay
so after our discussion yesterday that
first item is something that's already
implemented but I was going to disable
it because I couldn't I can't implement
it efficiently if the right hand side
has cyclic value but if the right hand
side is a single value it can be
implemented so what this is is just
general pattern matching in path this is
great do it
and if look if you're really worried
about what happens in the case where
the thing is cyclic and just produced a
message and say tough luck yeah yeah now
we have to because they can't do that
efficiently okay that's fine I mean just
say um can't be cyclic I mean I think
it's gonna be such a you know it's gonna
be so minor compared to the non cyclic
case yeah yeah well it doesn't really
make sense in this case anyway to have
sight cyclic color is there it's not a
let you swamp that's really nice to be
able to do this because that's a test
that allows you so okay that's the local
I see so that function that isn't just
local to that thing that could be global
to the stuff in the column is that true
you had those three slots that you were
filling in there is that correct well in
this case no it's only all it in this
case it only matches on the path right
it's just a it's just a pattern match to
to the paths as they're coming through
oh that's in this case any any path that
begins with okay what about the fouling
what about what about coloring well this
is just pattern matching it's not you
know general function application to to
something
it's just pattern no I understand that
but what we need is the thing that
allows you to color you can color by
value on the right hand side you can put
a function there which responds to the
value how that was the thing that has
three slots is that right right okay so
that's cool so if I say here um if I say
here oops how do I get to the mass for
example here oh not there okay so I want
to go I want what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna color
um pink every planet more massive than
the earth okay let's see if I can do
that alright so what I want to say so
that a day okay that doesn't involve
anything on the left hand side other
than just picking out the mask on but I
want to color the whole planet right
right okay so tell me how to do that god
um
so hash mass will pick out the mass
column right now why not what you want
is just list all come a mass that picks
out the mass column okay so just start
by coloring that cyan or something and
just to verify that that's correct okay
right right so now if you want to color
everything more massive than the earth I
want to color the whole of the of the
more massive than the earth you know
everything in the earth section okay
let's start just with this okay so here
what I'm imagining is if this ash 1
greater than earth mass right then pink
otherwise none see if I'm right
magnificent okay right that's nice and
that's by the way a decent example to
use but now I want to know how do I do
it so that I color whole of the Jupiter
section now so the third argument is the
entire data set and the second argument
is the path so alright so what I want to
do then is I want to say
in the entire data set wouldn't this be
just removing mice yeah I would be would
be but I don't know how okay so then if
hash three sub most of hash two sub mass
I think you want first of hash to know I
want to remove that you just want you
just want the planet right I want the
name of the planet yes
what do you know okay how do I get the
headers colored as well I had her
background did it you mean the row
headers yeah I'll be a similar thing
with header background
okay why didn't color those headers
there because you have this is a nice
mechanism by the way this is a nice
mechanism yeah so it it doesn't cover
look mmm the header background doesn't
color sub matters it only colors the
specific one that you get a pass to mmm
so I think there might need to be a
mechanism for that yeah okay I can look
into that okay all right let's keep
going by the way on our live stream SW
SH is talking about Apache arrow which
we have looked at but I would really
like to understand what the actual
architecture of that might be you know
it's what would you actually do oh it's
because data set has got to go
requesting data and most of the
operations of data set are not readily
compiled able well unless there's a
wolfram engine running inside the Apache
Aero system which there could be then
what this would have to do is it would
communicate with remote wolfram engines
to go get this work done I mean we've
had internally for years stuff with
Hadoop and I think now SPARC also
they're doing that for our internal
analytics but I think we'd never never
packaged it anyway it's an interesting
topic and if we can Devin maybe you can
pick that up as something I think sushma
has it on the list of projects we're
looking at I'm not sure what the state
of it is okay okay okay
items displayed and we're not calling
that machs items are we we're not
choosing to reuse the max items option
for this
we haven't talked about that mmm which
what functions use max items lots like
web image search and so on like text
search right I think there's an argument
we could reuse max items for this
probably seems highly relevant to me
yeah this seems highly relevant to me M
yeah all right let's plan on max items
for this okay now we're gonna have to
generalize a little bit here because
we're using okay so this is all so this
is basically oh my gosh what is this
creature here it's a horizontal
scrollbar that's horrifying
why it's wonderful I would like a some
kind of mini map to see roughly what's
going on before I start poking around
but look what right here we're talking
about the max items thing
um what's automatic it just uses a
heuristic to decide how many'd and the
items to show nice okay
okay so if you have limits if you have
limits on the first I'm talking about
this the last example there if you have
limits on the first two levels you get
scroll bars on internal levels you
either get the you know the 63 total
button or four four alighted columns you
get that thing there's no room to put a
total in there but if you hover over
that button it did shows you that if you
hover over the arrow so it would be
really nice to have internal scroll bars
but it's we we just we don't have the
technology right now to support that you
would require using nested grids and we
don't have a way of nesting grids nicely
so that they don't think things alone
I'm not totally convinced about I mean
I'd be happy to page through things I'm
not sure that score bars are better than
paging well no words in this case here
wherever you had it this case here I'd
be perfectly happy to see something at
the top here that says three more and
then page into it see I'm saying
be actually happier than the scrollbar I
don't even know what the scrollbar means
so well it means there's one left
well in this case there's one there
could be any number
so when you say so
so you click three three left what do
you what do you see the whole thing or
just what you've exposed or what I'm not
sure what I understand what you're
saying but a bit like here if we go to a
multi-page um let me make a multi-page
thing okay so let's say I say data set
range of a thousand or something right
okay so I could have what is that
scrollbar doing now Oh God
I don't like that I would prefer to page
through it well you can page through it
with by clicking yeah no I mean what
we've had previously if I go back to a
previous version okay what we have
actually I just done it for a reason
here um
what we have is this which I like I mean
what's wrong with this I prefer this are
you talking about this at the bottom yes
so we eliminated that because the
buttons at the end of the scroll bar are
the same functionality and that bottom
thing conflicts with the horizontal
scrollbar which you just put at the top
yeah but I mean why have that if you can
click the ends of the scrollbar it's the
same functionality I just prefer this is
a piece of UX I think of it as paging
whereas this is you know I think of this
know I hate it's like an iframe thing
with a bunch of pokey stuff in it
do we have any designers in this meeting
no we do no I don't like this and I mean
that the thousand total which is using
up that whole giant thing at the bottom
to just say that seems wrong I mean I
really like this well I can restore it
do you want to get rid of the buttons on
the end of the scroll bar no we could
leave those too I mean I think it's
convenient that both the convenient
things to do I don't think of this as
scrolling I think of it as paging I mean
look the fact is that performance is not
good enough for the scroll bar to really
be the interesting thing well maybe it
maybe I'm wrong here I mean I like being
able to page and given that we've got
that space at the bottom I don't see why
you shouldn't have something that's
paging like this okay now in terms of
the top so when is this getting
happening because that's a top scroll
bar it it happens if you limit the
number of columns but what happens if we
have both because on the one hand the
left bar since vertical but the pager
since horizontal I agree that's
confusing what do you what do you mean
so these arrows are going the wrong way
these arrows if we're gonna do this we
gotta have these arrows go up and down
but it depends how we visualize this
these tanks are they well we have given
ourselves no choice these chunks are
vertical based on the factors of
vertical scrollbar here
so I'm saying yeah so if they're both
scrollbars for a Sontaran vertical and
we teach you which direction you can I
went by much prefer what's that chain
change all the four and I had a tree
evaluate you get those crowbars so what
would Paige do go vertically or
horizontally all right we gotta have two
patron things here well I admit that in
this case but then this being down there
is kind of hopeless I mean that that's
you're gonna have this you've gotta have
some kind of opener here just like you
do for this case where you're well maybe
didn't do it in this case but for this
case where you have one of these where
opens or drills down to that mm what if
it's an enormous data said do you want
to show all no you don't well but what
do you do in this case if its enormous
it it'll scroll I see it'll skull
because it's gone to the next page and
then it Scrolls on the next page yeah I
really don't like this very much I mean
I I understand the argument for it I
just think it's not very nice I mean I
would like to see a um Steve on our live
stream is pointing out that it would be
nice to be able to resize by dragging a
corner we completely agree I mean that's
what table view does um I mean that's
that we would like to have but but
whether we have well I mean you're
convincing me that this is the only
feasible UX given the way with us
working but it will be lovely to be able
to say you're saying eight total but up
here you're not saying how many total
there are and you should
right this is almost other mentions like
falling off well but alternatively you
could say I mean that is referring that
eight total is referring to those keys
and I don't really know why this bar
extends over here I would have expected
that the eight total would be in that
column that's what I'm saying
yeah but because it here so you just
suggesting there should be a divider
that divides that into two and oh into
the eight total and a blank to the right
of it I'm scared it's gotta be a square
array no I understand I understand that
but you're right here I see you're
saying this represents more rows
basically eight total rows yeah okay so
the question is where does the thing
that says that there are however many
total columns go right because you
really want there are more columns and
you really want to say over here there's
more stuff you would like to say eight
total right here except you don't want
to do that because you don't want to use
the space and I put it mmm
okay for the for the scroll bar yeah if
it's an internal thing it it says it in
like when you hover over thee but but
why not using some sort of dimensions
notation so at the bottom we say eight
columns total times three
well we could say
eight total rows 3 semicolon three total
columns or better rows 1 to 4 of 8
semicolon columns 1 2 ts dream yep I
think so that would be good now
you know I might argue that we could
have paging buttons there as well right
as we just said in addition to this in
addition to these it somehow feels
cognitively different paging down here
mister scrolling up here so for both
columns and rows or that's what I'm
thinking where the columns where the
rows are vertically up and down so this
would read something like um rows okay
so there will be a down arrow I'm gonna
put it as a V here rows 34 2 of a
thousand okay and then we're gonna have
a I'm just gonna just some reason I'm
gonna do one of these okay wedge to
indicate that that's up and then columns
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba
so I think that's fine it's gonna be a
problem if the data set is very narrow
then punt on it if the data set is very
narrow drop all the words okay go down
to the point where you've dropped all
the words yeah if it's very narrow
perhaps you don't need to explain
anything about the columns well it could
be very narrow because you're only
showing one column of many yeah I see I
wonder whether we need the words rows
and columns here I think that this might
that that visually might work yeah try
it look so you only have one button
there you don't have a go to beginning
her end but just the paging buttons oh I
think it might be nice to have a
beginning an end with it with the bar
underneath it I think that might be nice
try it try it an awesome designer - yeah
okay another question in this example
you have right now the original data was
a vector
however it's represented as a table
right as a multi-column yeah so is that
the case in which would present also
controls four columns and guess not no
that's a reason why this verdict but by
not talking about rows is probably a
good thing in this case
by just having just you know ba ba ba
just use the the that to deal with this
um okay so another thing appearance
elements right do you support that so we
just get rid of the some of these pieces
right if you support support support
appearance elements you get rid of the
scroll bars if you don't want them then
okay yeah yeah because they can imagine
cases where only the paging is relevant
so Brian on the live stream is saying
please provide an option to suppress the
row column annotation in the scroll bar
annotation as in listing how many total
there are for example that's not a bad
suggestion I mean that will be an
appearance element I think yeah because
I can imagine cases were that the total
number is like really irrelevant oh you
know well you know you're kind of trying
to hide the fact that you're gonna have
to go through so many or something this
is nice this is a this is gonna be a
nice you exiting and we've got the space
down there in that bar yeah okay let's
move on um what's this
I don't understand why you comp little
three in there with a greater than sign
well its got like a wider what if it's
300 what about put but three underneath
what if it's 300 and it's trivial to do
I didn't do it because I thought we
wanted to be compact could we see if
Jeremy can join us sure yeah um I
understand if you
three thousand elements here or
something I I do like the way this looks
and by the way you really need a hover
effect as well as but as well as the
tooltip if you can get it um it doesn't
okay I thought I did it's it's really
small I was hard to see and even if
there is a hover effect it's gonna be
hard to see yeah now is that iconography
consistent yes it is that I can all
graffia consistent with this iconography
yeah I mean you could put a number there
if it isn't too big or is that silly um
hey here's another question when you
start off the data set you should be
able to tell it to display by default in
this drilled form right so I do actually
have an option for that which I provided
for testing but I haven't exposed it
it's called a guide be useful what's
that
it's called path not a great name for it
there is already a path option obviously
which is completely inappropriate for
this who just does that Jeremy Billy
okay yeah
we're looking at data
that and we are you're being thrown into
the middle of a kind of complicated
discussion okay
hello there
let's not rewind the whole thing that's
what we'll come back to this okay this
stay stay em stay alert um okay what's
this I've hidden everything in the
moon's gone and so what is that doing
I'll click it look that is not right
oh well okay it is right it is right
it's doing the right thing there yes but
so I haven't implemented this yet I
think there needs to be a difference
between drill down and that exposure
button the exposure button I think
should show you everything maybe it was
a scroll bar drilled down should should
pay attention to the whatever you
specify your items just laid wait wait a
minute drill down goes to a different
sub data set that is like a drilled page
and it's just a completely different
thing that you're displaying now but so
if you click moons or if you click that
exposure bed and they both drill down to
the same place fine okay but so that's
what I'm proposing that if you click
that exposure button it shouldn't be it
should ignore whatever you specified for
items displayed and show you everything
at that level
I understand how do you go back from
that so in particular what that would do
if I if I said all instead of zero now
then that would show the the moon's
columns yeah okay so the key thing is up
here it isn't really down here the key
thing is you lost columns that are had
headers up here right yeah so you think
that exposure error go up there I'm
thinking may
I'm thinking that this bar I think that
we less obscure that what that's doing
so let me just understand that the
problem is this is inconsistent okay
because this is a drill-down
right no no it's annex no it's an extra
laughter oh sure look it's a drill down
it drilled to Jupiter's moon yeah it's
it drills down that it also shows you
everything on their level maybe with a
scroll bar I understand that point I
understand that point what I'm saying is
that this is drill down and exposure
okay mm-hmm you want this case here to
be the same thing so the horizontal and
vertical exposure buttons work the same
way what I'm saying is if you click
Moon's to drill down there should still
respect whatever you specified for items
displayed so in other words if you drill
down to moons I should still see the 63
total here is that what you're saying
yeah because the moon's is only drilling
down to the all moon's level the 63
total is drilling down to the Jupiter
moons in the hole we'll wait why is that
saying all greater than oh I see I see I
see because that's just Jupiter moons
okay but is it obvious that there
shouldn't be a trailing Chevron in that
path down Jupiter greater than moons uh
well there never has been I understand I
just don't know if there should be to
show that it drills down into that
section yes
I think I need to pay further attention
to see what else is going on before I
answer that like comets are there now
because if you just replace the Chevron
with a comma you get what you need
fine okay who's this syntax okay so
what's the issue here the issue here is
that this drill down does so right so
right now you got a scroll bar and that
scroll bar thumb is wrong and I thought
that's crazy oh yeah you should show you
everything and you know all the columns
that were hidden yes it's crazy I mean
otherwise it's not compatible with these
right yeah it shouldn't keep itself
closed just as this doesn't can self
closed but then the quiz so the question
is if you click moons what should happen
should that also show you everything or
should it doesn't actually leave the
plane I think it should leave it with
closure with closedness because well
it's got to have it if it's got to do
this it's got to have no it's got this
now this is top level so now it has a
scrollbar sort of an exposure button the
thumb is wrong and okay so the question
auto open I don't think it should I
think it should leave it with whatever
is I think it should leave it like this
why sorry Billy
yes
I'm sort of expecting that when you
click that vertical bar it would appear
like the thing below it so you'd see
like the mass and radius is why does why
it does it do the other thing is that
because it's not implement I think
that's why I should work okay okay all
right so we're all agreeing that's the
way it should work all right we're agree
yes the way the experience should work
the question is what should drill down
to what should this drill down from the
headed yes yes should do the same thing
or should it respect what you specified
right as well okay so one of the issues
is given this state do we give people
away to show everything from this state
right if they want to expand this
obviously if we're gonna give them a a
dragger down there right resize handle
then they can do it that way but right
now there's no way for them to get the
thing resized mm-hmm which is bad
I mean one
we'll be to have a you know one of those
maximize buttons on the right of the
scroll bar which shows everything or
which adds an increment well you
probably want it just and like add some
to it I could go to the width of the
screen could show everything it can fit
on the screen or what about for the
vertical scrollbar no it shouldn't work
then I think there would be a thing
maybe it should be a thing that has you
know expander pushing outwards
you know horizontally associated with
the horizontal scrollbar to push out to
the width of the screen
you mean just you know what this is
stupid
I mean why aren't we just showing people
as much as we can I mean if it's gonna
go bonkers and go wider than the screen
the scrollbar is gonna pull it in but
otherwise just open it I mean why would
you want to not open it you know if it
fits on the screen you know this
horizontal real estate there I mean the
thing could be in some array right it
could be in a list and there might not
be horizontal real estate assume that
there is horizontal real estate I say
just open it as much as you can yes much
as you can you mean as much as will fit
yeah as much as will fit in the
horizontal real estate you have
available and everything beyond that
you've got a scroll anyway now the only
issue is how do you know how much
horizontal real estate you have and if
the data set is in a list that could be
to complicate complicated I don't know
but I mean you're saying that you
essentially are going to ignore items
displayed right so what's the point of
items displayed in the first place
should we maybe we shouldn't even have
items just note for colleges wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait you're saying I see you're
saying the only reason there's Alisha
elision is because there's an items
displayed yes
specification
well my guess is you should respect that
but really the issue is that you've got
to be able to say do you want the items
displayed to be definitively zero or do
you want it to be zero unless you
drilled right it's a zero unless you
drill see I'm saying okay the question
is is at zero at first or is it always
zero right now you just say it's zero I
had forgotten that this came from the
from the max items option right so if it
didn't come from max items if it came
from just restricting size on the screen
obviously on drilling it should open as
much as it can do we agree yeah okay so
this is the case where you've
artificially restricted it okay and the
question is should the artificial
restriction carry through or should it
unfurl itself when you drill down and
you could want either behavior in my
opinion yeah I think most more likely he
wants it to unfurl but I don't think
it's super obvious
um I mean if for example you drill down
to the mass column if you specified four
planets you presumably only want to see
four planets when you drill down to mass
absolutely
so in Israel no it shouldn't unfurl but
the question is when you specifically
press an an unfilled button for a
particular row or column okay
you're talking about the show more or
the the XX total button yeah yeah wait
here we we agree on that no no look look
in this case here this thing here yeah
that was a zero there right that's why
you're getting this right if I'd said
one here I would have had one column
already displayed right right okay I
think we've already agreed that that
should show everything when you when you
click that the only remaining question
is what happens with drill down
okay well given my initial statement
would be that given that you requested
the the closure the closing leave the
closing that's what I would suggest for
right now when you drill down when you
do drill down okay but I might change my
mind after I've actually used it yeah
okay top-level yeah
you've we've already gone over that okay
four rows with no items oh gosh yeah
this is just an improvement on the
formatting
oh I see here yeah oh that's just better
yep
so this syntax does not yet support
giving a different number of items
displayed for different branches of the
tree you can only specify then level how
would you even imagine doing four
different branches so you'd have to give
an association or something what would
you do well I see just like just like
other options yeah just like background
and so on whoa Oh a one all be three
okay fine so it has this it would have
the same character of being able to have
direct addressability yeah okay but I'm
not gonna cut that into twelve one fine
hidden items what is this oh boy so
there's interactive behavior you can
click those pluses to to expose things
you can right click or is this for
playing bingo or what it's useful if you
have a dataset which has a like a big
graphic you don't want it to expand the
dataset you can just hide that
individual item and if you right-click a
column header you can hide there hide a
column so there's that interactive
behavior well right column header well
like a one click you're right right
right-click that you can hide that
column then we'll head and hide cool
asaurus I mean that's nice and then hide
a nice design sorry plus see well right
so if you want to be able to expose
individual items there's got to be a
plus and every one the alternative would
be just to put the plus on the header
but then in the case where you did it by
closing like that I would say yes I
don't think I want to well but what if
you want to just expose a single item in
our row
I'm not going in there I'll call him
hover effect though it doesn't need to
show the plus immediately like you
imagine like slightly darker gray but it
hovers with the plus sign right hey I'll
be right back guys keep keep talking do
you want to share your screen for a
minute Chris I'll be I'll be panicking
like tonight okay so so what were you
suggesting Jeremy well the plus shows up
on hover but isn't there ahead of time
that way the noise isn't there you'll
just see one plus at a time I see but we
need some obvious right that means
hidden you know like if it were a darker
gray then say the column headings then
then maybe or we have some color or
something that means hidden cell that
could work what's Excel does something
like this but I forget how it works okay
I mean you can also you can explicitly
specify the background color of an item
what if one of those is hidden I mean I
think it's kind of nice to have things
hidden and and still have the continuity
of the background
I'm like I almost wanted to be a little
carrot instead and like the carrot
appears on hover and then you click in
it's like you're opening a drop-down
sort of but then I feel like it only
makes sense that only makes sense in
like the header or the far left vertical
bar could we use would it be too weird
to use like a like an eyeball where it's
like you know you're hiding and showing
yes yeah Billy suggesting we should use
eyeball icon yeah you generated here
okay so so Jeremy you had have you have
been suggesting something I mean I think
plussing the whole column is silly I
agree that you could do something on
hover I think whoops that's not what I
wanted I hope right click I say hide
column okay so I think putting a plus up
there makes sense but I don't see any
point in having pluses all the way down
what other people think that do you
think it makes sense to be able to
expose hidden items individual hidden
items sure but excuse me I'm mouse over
you can show them right yeah I think
that's fine Jeremy said suggested the
background color should change to show
you that it's hidden I agree yeah well
the difference between hidden and
missing so I'm not sure how you do that
ahead of time yeah no I Sachin would be
a good metaphor for hidden
does it conflict with the cloud loading
cross-hatching or does it sit right in
there
zip feel like it's sort of because
that's sort of what that means it's it's
there I mean we might yeah okay the
thing I don't like about a different
background is it destroys the continuity
of the background and you've got a
different background for hidden things
which yeah you know what with respect to
cross hatching what I realize is when we
have remote data coming in we will need
that kind of cross hatching so it'll be
have to be a different cross hatching um
or something I mean I don't know design
foe what do you think we should do I
mean I agree we need to not have this
look like missing it needs to be that it
is absent it's closed could we maybe
thicken up the borders so that way it's
sort of like folded in on itself so if
the edges were coming together it would
maybe appear no up I was unemployed in
the whole array dot dot dot dot dot will
be a lot less distracting than plus
signs and in the headers plus or dot
plus okay that's what I think in other
words anything you explicitly closed um
okay we have various comments on our
live stream here including don't imitate
Excel where it's really easy to miss
hidden columns I have noticed that yes
I mean having dots would help that yeah
like I just tried it in Excel also after
Jeremy had commented it's like I'm still
having trouble on hiding the column that
I had a hit well
the cell borders the worthies cell
horizontal cell lines continue or
whether we get rid of the horizontal
cell lines and just have dots I suspect
it'll look okay to just have dots dots
are much better
hi I just mocked that it looks much
better than Plus and I kind of see did
you uh y'all male you
common to
um okay um okay so then pastrami
Receptus yeah it's pretty nice actually
looks nice okay
I like it um shouldn't have her to plus
then or hot what should the hover be
yeah I think so yeah when you're showing
an actual value there which is fine I
think on hover but it should hover why
not the when I have the thing hover to
plus which indicates that there's an
action you can take by clicking it and
then have it hover with the value mm-hmm
I will tip the value okay so max items
and hidden items okay so your
affirmative lis hiding I guess that's
right I guess that's the right thing to
do same thing
I have to specify true or false okay
right that's using your drill down to
get to a three I understand if I just
did the three there would that hide
everything that has a key of three yes
okay
slightly wild but perhaps useful okay
what's this now
it's just syntax for rows and columns
okay now if you were to hide something
in the middle would we have a plus for
the thing hidden in the middle I guess
yeah if I ate a next one that seems okay
better than a doll - doll could mean
something completely different oh wait a
minute
you're suggesting that should be I'm
saying anything you affirmative Li Hyde
is a plus but if there is implied hiding
like a whole columns worth of stuff the
thing other than the explicitly then the
head of the hiding like the column
header should be dotted that's what I'm
saying
so what have you interactively okay so
right-click the three on that one and
hide it
this thing here yeah like that okay now
there's gonna be a plus and a bunch of
dots and now you click a dot in the
middle that dot changes to a plus well
and hover it changes to a plus okay and
then and when you're explicitly if you
explicitly hide it it stays as a plus I
think okay if you profoundly don't want
the plus you can always hide and unhide
and you only have a mouse you can hide
and unhide the the whole column and
it'll go back to a dot okay okay what
does that do this is just illustrating
if you use you can use false in order to
make an exception - it's a little weird
but it's okay okay okay right you've
seen that you've seen that you've seen
interactivity yeah the next one okay
what's this gonna be
right so I've hidden the moon's column
and I still show the structure under the
moon's column I see you interactively
hid that column so I could interact so
in this case we know that that's gonna
be a plus and a bunch of dots right the
point is I haven't hidden all the
structure it hasn't the whole thing
hasn't collapsed down to nothing
which makes it possible to show things
that are there what do people think
about that in other words you could do
the same thing that you're doing with
the mass column and just I mean Jeremy
is it easy for you to Mach dotting this
creature or do you have to press a dot a
large number of times to do that yeah I
can dot that I mean III would think a
common case would be you just want to
hide it though and you don't want to
expose all that structure so maybe you
want to expose one piece and she's short
cut it by you know hiding the whole
column I think more likely just wanna
hide the whole column weird I wouldn't
think so - I don't understand why you
need to see that structure yeah I want
to see that structure why did you hide
the sub columns okay this is gonna be
expensive to implement but well that's
fine we're not sure it's right I mean
look I know I should it's right to
change what you've done so so the way it
works now is whenever it encounters an
item it just says am i hidden or not and
it replaces it with a plus if it is if
it's gonna actually hide the whole
column that has to restructure the out
thing of the data set in order to do
that which is a lot more okay hold on
hold on what are you saying you're
saying it right now you are simply
asking for every given item is it hidden
or not right which doesn't change the
structure of the output grid whereas if
it's going to hide the whole column it
actually changes and structured us why
it's a bigger task to implement
um livestream is saying think you need
an option to hide the hidden rows
columns so only the requested rows
columns are shown in other words hide
everything but show the ones I want to
show I think that's what you have with
that false mechanism but I think I mean
you can't question here that you might
want the labels to be shown but dots and
the but could you get that yes you can
get that you can get that just fine I
mean if I go if I click that and now I
hide this yeah and I hide this I'm in
great shape
yeah oops that happened there
no right so it's a bug well it's not a
bug it's so the way it works now is if
everything and a column is hidden then
the column is hidden so it just hides
the whole thing I don't think that's
right I think if you hide that sub
column you shouldn't be hiding the outer
column right I mean I just hid the
radius column I didn't hide the moon's
column which is an autumn that's wrong
yeah but I think I would be I mean if
it's really an implementation horror
right now to turn the moon's thing into
a pure you know dotting for each row I
wouldn't worry about that yet but I
think the thing we just saw is wrong
Jeremy or Billy or anybody do you have
an encounter comments illness I agree I
was getting distracted by that the moon
names like it doesn't say names at the
top so then how do you I mean I guess
you right-click but I mean to do what I
guess I'm just wondering why it isn't
the the first column isn't well it isn't
really a column those are keys I see for
the rows then that's not a column we
could have a differently structured data
set where it actually is a column
it might help for orientation to mark
these cells like perhaps I'm thinking of
a diagonal like what yes so this sir
that really was referring to the one
that is right under moon's this one here
that's all if that cell had something it
would represent like this is drilling to
a deeper level what does what happens
when you press that nothing nice imagine
that that that had a diagonal from north
west to southeast same thing for for the
main one that should actually drill down
if you click it didn't the problem is
there's nothing there's no target there
and it's it may be hard to hit that's
another discussion item but I was
thinking oh I did the test will you
drill down now yeah the heck is that
that's the key words I completely
confused about what happened that it's
you drilled down two keys I didn't
invent that that's what the what data
said has done a whole long to find a way
of representing the fact that there is a
deeper level there that we are at level
three because it's a bit confusing to
find the names of the moons well here
look if you look at the if you look down
at that and then the base there it says
keys or all moons all keys right right
yes
but perhaps there is something this one
that somebody just annotated the which
level number
well I mean what's wrong with with on
hover showing something in there we
could do that even the word keys in
there what to tell you what would happen
if you clicked it oh boy this is
complicated you can also sort by keys if
you're right right click if you can find
the right place down yeah in that cool
that is cool
that is cool so in other words there is
annotation that goes into those things
but look I agree that anything where
there's kind of a dumb okay so here I
presumably can also sort by keys yeah if
you can find the right place to click I
mean that the cursor should changed a
finger yeah that's cool that's really
cool now I'm sorry Jose could you repeat
what you were suggesting yes I was
compelling when we do matrix form of
something of depths three or more the
fact that there are additional braces
helps a lot in in knowing that you are
in a deeper thing here if you look at
the data set in general sometimes it's
not so easy to note which level you are
other than going and hovering and really
unacceptable so I would like something
which is more this word immediate and I
think those cells that are the key to
this orientation well they are those
cells right now have no information in
them exactly so perhaps a different
height different color I think that's
gonna look ugly but but I think well I
see what you're saying so one thing you
could imagine is that the gray level
could change for keys that are at a
deeper level see what I'm saying yeah
because it isn't always keys it could be
it could be a pure I mean if I were to
take for example let's say I do this
let's say I say array you know a random
and I go like six six six here okay now
I go that's not what I wanted
silly me okay um and now I go um
data set of that okay so now what the
heck am I looking at what am I looking
at here so I'm looking at what what the
heck am I looking at here there's a six
by certainly which expands to six oh and
then there are six down right if I want
another level of sickness well here let
me just go six eight six eight oh that's
not good what did that just do why
didn't it show me six eight six eight
its I have not messed with tallies
heuristics for how to structure data
sets I think you need to well I I agree
but it's that's a big project that I
haven't tackled yet okay all right okay
fine so that's not good what that did I
don't even understand what this is doing
up here oh I see that's that that's the
number right that's item two Row two
column five so this is sort of thing in
which matrix form has a nicer way of
helping or in orienting so you're saying
in the case of matrix form here if I say
matrix form of this but probably I mean
the numbers may be a bit too large yeah
but here it's very easy to know when you
are at a deeper level by counting all
these places
so I was trying to find an equivalent or
you know which you could do with some
kind of if we had some kind of Ledger's
indicating the outside where it got
deeper and deeper exactly which is - as
such as a bit precious but there might
be a way of thickening the edges of
something generally any thought so
anybody you know we had talked about
that and I and early on I proposed I
mean I had a mock-up of that I think it
would be a good thing to do it sighs
okay surprisingly difficult to do all
right but that's for the future and I
think the dead cells so we got two
issues and which we need to note down
we've got dead cells which is what I'm
calling those things that have no
content right there are purely
structural elements those were easy to
identify
then you would know immediately that you
are two level sleeper well I would say
if you had a clue in the dead cell right
what level the dead cell was that like
for example you could have something you
have a little nick and that slight
little little thing there and you could
have two little Nick's if it's deeper
right like that that seems fairly non
stupid actually to me what Jeremy and
Billy think about that I make sense to
me yeah I like it
is there any concern for getting
confused with those things and text
boxes it looks similar like sort of like
that and you click and drag it - not if
you do a good job of - Lajoie - okay
what's the mark by moons the bottom
right I think that was just Billy
probably adding up okay
all right um okay question from Brian
livestand how do you add column or row
headers for unstructured data such as a
list of values yeah I mean all of these
headers are made from associations this
is a data set is a list of associations
of associations of Lists you know it's a
nested collection of associations and
lists and so all of these headers are
actually keys in an association and
that's the way that's being done and
it's not just a appliqué you know our
headers they're really part of the data
okay drill down here
what's this that's the same thing we've
just seen right yeah I mean it if you
drill down to Mars it just illustrates
that drilling down prover preserves
hidden items okay but in the future what
this is gonna be is just a plus there
and a dot there yes and that is a very
unfortunate tooltip look at it it's
discord is small I can't I can't read it
type good grief
well that's obviously wrong card game
yeah I got a screenshot okay okay
sorting I don't think that's terrible
yeah I don't think that's terrible we
know how far back data sets yet well we
will eventually have just planning for
the future
yeah obvious they would have to
cashed I mean there's a bunch of stuff
look if we were doing I mean that's a
thing for our database back-end um Edie
on our live stream is saying a dead cell
represents two levels one of them one
isn't that correct yes story that yeah
because because there's rows and columns
so that is actually at the third level
right it dislike matrix form so II don't
live stream is suggesting that it could
represent or Edwin I don't know um is
suggesting that it could um represent
both its horizontal and vertical level
that you know that could be like a slash
and one and two on the upper left and
then three and four which I think would
probably be pretty ugly no I mean the
question is is there a good metaphor
with these slashes for example to
indicate it's I'm so confused it's it's
column depth and it's row depth
basically yeah right that's what we're
talking about so it could means inter
arrows like we take a coordinate system
so you you put two or one depending on
how many levels you're running
no I was thinking something like a small
vertical arrow you know Jose you can
draw just go to the go to the header and
go to more and you can go to the
annotation tools go under the more
button and the um and the zoom header at
the top it says you're viewing stephen
wolfram screen view options and then
second from the bottom above follow
presenters pointer annotate I know I see
so see that was well what the arrow down
mean I don't understand that it's its
direction of one level but that doesn't
tell you what the levels are right you
know what you need to know is that that
dead cell is already deep in the
drilling so to speak yes so each of
these arrows represents one of them I
know but you've got to see non-locally
all the arrows to know what level you're
at whereas the whole point of the
slashes is that just looking at that
cell you can immediately tell you at
level 3 and that is relevant if you've
done drill down then that you're still
seeing that that was a level 3 drill
down I see yeah I was looking for
something that indicates there's a new
level the parallelism is with metric for
each of these new braces is two levels I
think this requires more thought but I
think the slash is another terrible
place to start and maybe what we can do
how about like a light gray number so
above mercury there would be in line
with the mercury there'd be a 1 and then
to the left of mass there be a 2 I think
we want iconography not numbers
[Music]
um let's see Brian is such a blur and
suggested putting numbers in there but
but um then a dot or other icon in each
row and column that is a new level I
agree that having that thing on hover
give numbers is fine um although I don't
know I think the numbers um I'm still
little confused about what this is doing
here anyway I mean so I don't understand
how the arrows help I mean what's that
tell you more than no I think they're
glowing slashes just saying it's a
deeper level how deep that level is how
deep that thing is that seems relevant
but I agree that it'd be nice to know
the horizontal depth so I'm a little
confused it requires more thought Chris
I think you need to think about it
because I my um
I know that if you can clear your
annotations that'll be good otherwise
when I scroll they'll still be there
maybe the design team can think about it
okay
dynamic data set so data set was kind of
broken within dynamic or manipulate it's
not anymore hit it's fully functional
good for you there's nothing more say
about it no okay great that's really
good so this is what we were just
talking about that there's no target to
hit and those blank cells dead cells we
can call them yeah okay we use so if
it's if the data set is for planet data
and then the thing like Phobos Deimos or
astronomical names is there could we add
that information into no that all you
have is what you have this is just a
random example this data set could be
you know Turtles captured at a beach or
something
I mean this just one random example make
sense yeah yeah okay interactive
controls maybe I think we've gone
through that drill down does show more
we've talked about that that's
truncation function truncation display
okay so this is not yet implemented I'll
actually play it's in limited in part
you can try evaluating that I don't know
if you're yeah it works so this gives
you control over a when and how things
are truncated and there's two options
one determines when and the other on
suicide no because we actually need this
for a completely different project
Tom's data structure visualization
project needs exactly this so in his
case you know you're displaying a linked
list or something like that
yeah and you know it's got elements that
are giant how do you elide those right
we were just planning a whole discussion
about that I've been waiting to ask if
this at all ties in like when this ties
in well we just we just found out this
seems complicated Chris and I'm not sure
this is the right there's a bug there
but if you evaluate the one before that
it makes the point it just that is it in
addition to the truncate tation function
it's specifying how to display the
truncated things I understand that's not
that's because I think yeah you don't
have the latest build okay just put that
in okay I think this is a little
premature this truncation stuff I mean
you might want some default behavior but
I would there is some default behavior
right now right yeah yeah I mean I would
I would be perfectly happy to put this
off until post twelve point one because
there's a there's a big chunk of it that
I haven't implemented yet but I think
that there's a this general problem of
truncation and religion is something we
need to address
okay so and we might also dress it for
expressions in general that you might
have an expression that has parts that
are lighted and you click on them and it
opens it out we've wanted to do that for
at least 20 years there would be agile
mechanism not specific to dataset right
that's correct yeah I think we we have
had designs for that a lighted form and
so on I believe I had designs 20 years
ago for that so it's useful for graphics
and images too in what sense really long
graphics or images or you know weird
aspect ratios it'd be useful have a
truncation function for it would be yes
it would be very useful
so look Chris I think this should be a
general thing which should be
specifically applied to data set and I
think we need a meeting sooner rather
than later about it in connection with
the data structure visualization project
so I think that's getting set up so
bring it up there in my view but I
wouldn't worry too much about it for
this again I mean just do some automatic
thing that's not totally terrible right
it's there already this is a way of
specifying that parts of a data set are
atomic items so you reported this where
evaluate that it kind of screws up the
display oh yeah oh that's absolutely
horrible I know what should the issue is
bright so those allowed tiles things are
actually individual their atomic things
but it thinks are part of the data set
he thinks that two level lists as part
of the data sets dry under stun but it
is really in a matrix basically yeah so
this is not yet implemented but the
proposals TEVAR atomic items where he
can specify the level I'm not sure I
like the name I mean how are you
specifying it so similarly okay really
what this is is it some kind of wrapper
around those items that says don't
expand that don't display it it's a
display issue it's not so much atomic in
the sense of you know a map another
drill down of that kind boy it's so
confused
we have a we have a notion of things
like this in this physics project never
mind it's a it's a it's really confusing
between what Democritus thought atoms
were versus what Adams became in
chemistry versus for that I'm sorry
yeah it's really confusing um okay uh I
don't think atomic items is the right
name for this but I understand the
concept I'm not sure so how are you
referencing this so this is basically
like your other things you are able to
specify rows and columns and the same
way that you can do for background and
so yeah that's like it's like it would
be red or just don't break this down so
to speak yeah should this be called I
mean I admit that boy see the other
problem is that by the time you got max
items saying what the maximum number of
items is and this kind of like leaves
just where the leaf is how deep the tree
can go which does sound awful like
atomic items scalar items
hmm yeah
he won't abate him I don't really ever
be needed for levels that contain lists
or associations I understand a data set
right now does not have an allowed heads
concept that would allow it to break
down I mean let's say you had some other
rapper other than list by the way that
would be a wonderful use for the dead
cell is indicating what if there was a
function f and you had nested FS instead
of nested lists you could imagine a
dataset breaking that down yeah I'm
putting the F in the dead cell but what
could we do here I understand the
concept by the way Nikola and our live
stream is reporting the fact that on
Linux you can't horizontally scroll for
the mouse only vertical scrolling works
horizontally I mean you can't scroll the
data set and previous versions
horizontally scrolling scrolling
something else I don't know okay oh I
see
okay yeah I think I think this just
didn't work previously okay anyway so so
atomic items um I mean this is
oh boy I do not have a good name for
this now I'm admitting that so far
atomic items is better than nothing I'm
coming up with anybody else got any
thoughts here Chris did you consider
other names for this no I mean the only
one that's occur to me is leaves leaf
items
so I will be leaf items basically its
deepest items basically or wetware
undrilled items on what would be the
right term for that data items no that
could be almost anything
it's things where you didn't break
inside it you didn't go um impervious
items max level items that's awful
impervious I don't think that's that's
not gonna help anything but I agree that
that's and is it the term items the
right thing that's what's generally used
and I mean they're all all the options
generally refer to item unless there's a
radius option like background doesn't
have vitamins name
so the idea is to specify the header the
path to where they all are so you have
to have one level deeper right yeah what
do you mean or the path to where
everything is that can't be opened yes I
was trying to compare we have a similar
situation in outer and outer there are
some numbers at the end let's say how
deeply oh yes that's right that's a very
analogous thing which we could one day
turn into an option yes it's a path
toward the Brian on live stream is
suggesting indivisible items which is
better than atomic I have to say yes
things that can't be split can't be
broken apart you know indivisible items
is really not bad and doesn't get us
into the whole Democritus you know the
the legacy of Democritus type stuff no
that's their way way too weird
I mean scaler as in not vector yeah
that's too weird
that assumes of you know the the
symmetric space with hanging around or
something um I would say indivisible
items is the most promising that we've
heard so far I'm just gonna looking at
the Tsarist gravy elementary no because
that again is like could be simple
unfortunate death doesn't work because
it's not a depth it's it's an actual
location or the synonym undividable
right but I think I like indivisible but
okay is it the is it
correct that what you are giving is
indivisible items or are you giving us
Jose is suggesting some deeper thing
well let me understand that so why are
you putting that other older it probably
is not necessary but if ever over what
are the smoky it's important because
that makes the whole thing go one little
deeper well I mean it would suffice to
just say allowed you know all the things
in the allowed tiles level I think you
probably wouldn't need that yeah I don't
think you need the or I think they all
is very confusing yeah I think so but
that then it's ambiguous because what
happens if allowed tiles is a contains
lists of indivisible objects
how do i express that well then you
would go one level yeah there you go one
level more so this is saying indivisible
items okay hold on this to go one level
deeper here if we were doing this with
backgrounds right so let's say we do the
thing here where we say all right even
get this thing out that is the data set
can I can I just go ahead and say I hope
I can data set of that with now you
cannot currently you will be able to but
it's not implemented yet
well I can say first of that probably
all that work yeah you can try it
doesn't have it doesn't have a decent
output form yeah I worked
no it didn't the first I should that
work just fine yeah okay so now what I'm
saying is you don't want to say okay so
I claim that in your calculus of back
rounding that if I say all and then
allowed tiles arrow pink okay so I'm
claiming that everything there if
everything there is indivisible how I
see what you're saying you're saying
what if you want to be able to say each
one of those is indivisible right so if
I were to say this I will be the same
thing would be visibly the same thing so
yeah you're right
you're right
perhaps what's needed he has precise
their combination with what outer dance
which is once you are at the level of a
large tiles you say a number which is
how many more levels you would have to
go until you find their atoms no but you
can you can say that here all you do is
allowed tiles all look if I wanted to
look here if I say three all that will
do that right that will only go that
will go whereas if I said all it's okay
I mean it's a little funky that you do
it's not a level here you're just
specifying the all's down to the point
where you get to the indivisible stuff
like it's okay all right
let's go and divisible items thanks to
Brian on our live stream for that
suggestion seemed reasonable yeah okay
please don't call it pause um display
state I
call this this particular thing dataset
display path may be something very
specific like that that reasonable yeah
and then dataset scroll position for
your other hidden option okay so you
said earlier you thought path should be
exposed yeah and it could be later on
with that name dataset display path is a
perfectly okay name so just put it in
you can consider it hidden or unten I'm
not sure I wouldn't go too
I wouldn't document it well display
state display path I would say that's
possibly expose abour I wouldn't
document these right now we've got
plenty of other stuff to figure out but
I would call it dataset display path
dataset scroll position so there in our
document should they appear on options a
dataset
sure it's fine okay is scroll position
the right name and what does it mean the
position of the scroll bar thumb in
counting in in units of a scroll down to
the third item here yeah I see okay but
I mean in principle you could say earth
and something else right but I probably
you don't support that yet no it was
going to mention that so what's the
difference between bath and position are
in day the same thing says a path uses
allows keys
yeah except that we don't have an
efficient way to support using the
specifying numeric positions instead of
keys if there were an internal function
which would I could give a a key and get
the corresponding numeric position I
could do it otherwise I think that was
just a spur on the ILD meets it you
could put in something on the function
of posit or e and we don't know how
efficient it can be yet that would be
very useful
okay I think you are possibly its only
potential user but that's fine um all
right so let's talk about this for a
second the scroll position let's see the
path is telling you the display path is
telling you what panel is displayed
where you drill down to I mean maybe
it's name should be data set display
panel and then the other one could be
data set display scroll position very
long but Tim list it says what it is
because one of them
it's you know what do you think data
said drill down I know like drill down I
think that's a very we haven't used that
sort of family of words at this parent
but they don't understand is why why one
is up and up the other is opposition
didn't give a good of power but they
could both be positions
mm no unless I'm confused by something
oh I suit you're saying you're saying
are you saying okay I see a suit you're
saying you're saying the top levels are
scrollable - no that's not right it's
not right because you couldn't drill
that the question is those levels have
they been drilled through and you are at
a separate page or panel or are they
merely scrolled - I think what I'm
saying is that the panel is specified
through a path which I still think it's
a positions is that it happens to
support keys but it also as a panel it's
the question of what you're displaying
are you displaying it as a separate
panel or are you displaying it merely by
scrolling to that point yeah they're
different different concepts right
because I mean if I go click you know
this guy here I'm gonna go down to that
different display panel right think
about that as the display panel as
opposed to I'm on this display panel
open that out I thought that didn't that
open all the moons
well anyway let's assume it opened the
moons then I would still have a scroll
position with the moons get what I'm
saying yeah okay
could it be dataset branch
it's the branch of the tree you're
displaying oh god no nobody's gonna
understand that why do you not like
display panel because panel is a
particular thing it's not I mean it's
not a Wolfram language panel isn't it I
mean it could be
we need a name for those I mean could be
display page but I don't like that very
much
I proposed dataset display panel dataset
scroll position but you can consider
them as hidden options for the time
being okay set cell oh gosh we've got
those in notebooks I mean that's even
more confusing visiting a grid what is
the language used for grids item I mean
the cells of a grater of the items yeah
I understand
but this isn't that at all now I think
these are the decent names for now um
Brian on our live stream is asked is
there a mechanism to put a scrollbar on
a lower level the answer is no and the
reason for that is we just think it's
just irreducibly confusing it's not a
fair statement I think it could be nice
it's I mean there's technical issues
that presented prevented me from doing
it this far
okay all right fair enough so I wonder
whether that's a thing I mean when
that's probably gonna be some appearance
elements mechanism all right do we get
to the end of the agenda as one more you
would ask for annotated scrollbar thumbs
so that it shows you where you are when
you're scrolling but we don't have the
technology to support that fine don't
worry about it but that is not the thing
that's kind of you know especially when
we've got those annotations at the
bottom that say showing blah blah blah
blah yeah should be just fine okay
all good all right we made it through
okay is that everything for the that you
know of for the yes yeah is everything
that you need to give your blessing to
okay it's wonderful stuff now let's make
sure it's all efficient and then let's
make sure that we can back it with
things and pure in memory stuff and also
please please make sure that the store
and notebook okay so remember the way
it's going to work is there's the store
a notebook option
and then when you cloud publish the
thing or actually there really should be
another option in addition to store in
notebook which is store and persistence
location see what I'm saying
so in general right there are multiple
persistence locations that you could be
using right so if I say dollar
persistence locations persistence path
here I'm I don't know if you know this
whole mechanism right there's there's
those are the difference in persistence
locations does this make any sense
yeah I've seen that now what's
interesting about these persistence
locations which we probably should bring
up is there isn't a notebook persistence
location but that could be see what I'm
saying mm-hmm
but are you suggesting that the the
store a notebook button should offer
alternatives yes
which would be the same for sparse array
and everything else that uses I think so
because I mean here's the thing here's
the thing you could store it in the
notebook but you could also say I don't
want to store it in the notebook I want
to store it in a private cloud so if I
send this notebook to somebody instead
of it being a hundred megabyte matrix
that I have to send as part of the
notebook email I've got my hundred
megabyte matrix that's stored in the
private cloud and the person can
retrieve it if they care mm-hmm be nice
I think we have all the plumbing to do
that I think it's just a question of
what the UI is for the store in whatever
so anyway I think we have a meeting
that's supposed to get set up and Devon
should check this about that topic
yeah sure system and please when you
bring that when we do that can we bring
up why there isn't a persistence
location notebook okay yeah and wait so
this is all formats match thing right I
think Matt is the person yes
um alright excellent beautiful wonderful
um-hum word oh I'm sorry
table view you're gonna figure out I
mean whatever I guess we have another
review of table view can you make sure
you Kris are in the meeting about table
view okay who is arranging that well
there'll be somewhere around John okay
I'll ask John then um okay I don't know
whose p.m. until maybe there is no p.m.
for table view because purely within the
front end group then maybe parts would
know okay okay excellent right thank you
thank you thank you and thanks to people
on the live stream as well lots of very
helpful suggestions much appreciated
okay CEO I